nelson lamette ready to go tonight well
it's down matching and making his six
start the 28 year old has been throwing
the ball extremely well
and this one is in the air foul ground
third base way machado going as far as
he can and he makes the catch up against
the screen nicely done by manny machado
in foul ground for out number two
he covers the whole ballpark
back-to-back walks and the padres have
two on with two down and the padres with
an opportunity to do some damage now
here in the first inning with will myers
standing in and myers grounds one off
the glove of frazier at third into short
left here comes machado around manny
will score to third goes hosmer and the
padres take a one-nothing lead
well myers driving in the first run of
the night
in and out of this starting lineup
swings at the first pitch pops it up
foul ground it's hedges and machado and
it's manny machado into the slide to
make the catch nicely done by machado
racing into foul ground right in front
of the texas rangers dugout machado goes
into the slide makes the catch
line to left field and that's going to
get in sharply by solac the left fielder
and machado's headed for second base
throat goes there but in there standing
is machado with a one-out double
and a grounder right side under the
glove of santana into right field
machado being waved around here's a
throw from wright and gallo gonna be
close and he is out
tag applied by the catcher trevino on
machado
as gallow throws him out from right
field for out number two
and a swing and a miss lumet with his
sixth strikeout one down here in the
fourth inning well as you mentioned in
this inning a lot of pitches so a little
calm down right there gather himself
a little breather and a swing and a miss
as lumet strikes out dietrich strikeout
number seven ends the top of the fourth
one-nothing padres
breaking ball and that one
is lined into left field so the rangers
do have their first hit
isaiah who's
in dire need of a hit and great start to
the fifth and now here's trevino
trevino that's a big swing that's
carrying well gone
a two-run homer for jose trevino his
first of the year
and just like that the rangers are in
front 2-1
there's a liner that's in the
left-center field for austin hedges
rudolph single start sings here in the
bottom of the fifth inning runner goes
and fernando swings and lines one into
left field for a base head
stopping at second his hedges he was off
with the pitch
and the padres have runners in first and
second with one down first hit of the
night for fernando tatis jr he is so
good at baseball
in each of the first three games of this
series
the scene is set
no team has hit a grand slam in four
consecutive games
ever you're talking like major league
baseball history i'm talking about ever
in the air to right field towards the
corner it's back it's gone
welcome to slam diego
grand slam for eric cosberg for the
first time in major league history a
team has hit
a grand slam in four consecutive games
and that team is the san diego padres
eric cosberg for the grand slam
slam diego you're out
you see twice the starter
this one out in a center field base hit
for kiner falefa his second of the ball
game
3-2 and this ball hit sharply and into
left field base hit trevino stops at
third base
and the rangers have him on the corners
with two out
and they're loaded now for the rangers
with two down danny santana makes his
way
2-1
and that ball belted to center field
it's got a chance and it is knocked down
a defense
two runs are in three runs score
and this one is tied at five on the
bases clearing double by santana
almost a grand slam
we've talked about you know in the last
couple days some of the adjustments he's
made to get back there
broken back flare out to center field a
good way to start
the eighth inning all right trevino two
run homer in the fifth inning this ball
hit hard base hit into left field
that'll get gallo to the plate and the
rangers have the lead
it's 6-5 in the eighth have a night jose
trevino very nicely done in a big spot
here's ty france second it back
one two in the air left field well
struck solak going back he's on to the
warning track he's at the wall he looks
up it's gonna go
home run ty france to tie the game
six six here in the eighth hedges will
hit for himself here in what is now a
tie game hedges hits this in the air to
deep left field back goes solac at the
oh it's gone
austin hedges with a home run
padres go back to back in the eighth and
take a 7-6 lead
austin hedges look at how fired up he is
top of the ninth inning now and the
rangers are going to have to get a run
at least one against this ball this one
lined out to right field that one's
carrying well myers is back it's gone
solac
with a solo shot the other way
second home run of the year
and he's tied the game at seven in the
ninth grown worth beginning the day
leading in virtually every offensive
category among national league rookies
and a chance here to walk it off to the
san diego padres kronerworth up the
middle into center field around will be
myers no yes it's kicked in center
heidemann misplays it and myers scores
at the padres for the second straight
night have walked it off and they sweep
the texas rangers in a four-game series